it is the 1st of December 2023 and we
are now getting close to wrapping up the
entire year so it's time for another
monthly update video I'm going to tell
you what we did during November what
we've got coming up in December and what
you might want to put on your calendar
or get in on I always like to begin with
three big things so big thing number one
we still have a vote going on for who
the last three slots in Worlds of
speculative fiction 2024 are going to be
uh I opened it up a few days ago I'm
going to keep it open for a little while
longer you can see the link below so if
you want to get in on that action go
ahead and click that link and check it
out big thing number two I've got a new
academic publication out which has to do
with ancient philosophy ophy and anger
management I'll put a link to that below
it's in my Phil people profile so you
can read that if you'd like to Big Thing
number three and this is kind of a much
bigger thing having to do with
2024 there's going to be some
announcements for online classes in the
study with Sadler Academy I'm going to
be doing some synchronous online classes
some asynchronous online classes some
email classes a lot of cool stuff that's
going to be coming your way these are an
open enrollment so you don't have to be
uh you know in academic institution to
learn about philosophy with me so if
you've wanted to take a class with me
there's going to be opportunities for
that I'm going to talk about that just a
little bit later in this so those are
the three big things uh for this
month November was a busy month uh as
many of of you know many of you from
experience here in the United States we
have the Thanksgiving holiday so that
means basically a whole week as far as
academic work gets kind of shot and we
spend time with family and we eat turkey
and other things as well so I had my
kids here and we had a great time we did
some fun things including going to
almost home cat uh rescue and hanging
out with them it's also been a busy
month academically you know it's getting
to be crunch time we have to like decide
what new classes we're teaching next
semester so there's all of that going on
as well but I did hold my monthly ask me
anything session we did worlds of
speculative fiction this time focusing
on Terry pratchett's disc World Series
we looked at five of the rince wind
novels and that was a lot of fun we
restarted classic metal class me and
Scott terui my good friend and colleague
from Berkeley School of Music and uh
that was great to get that going once
again Scott and I have an excellent
Rapport and we talked about a lot of
really cool topics and went on quite a
lot longer than uh either of us had
anticipated that it would uh we did
wisdom for Life uh the radio show and I
released the video for that I also did a
Philosophers in the midst of History
talk locally here in Milwaukee uh on
David Hume the video for that you can
find below link to in the video Des
description
and I did another ideas that matter
conversation one that also went on quite
long with t Virgil Murthy we talked
about uh boraste that was the official
topic but we got into translation we
unpacked some of Borge's short stories
and ideas and we straight off into a lot
of other great areas of discussion as
well there were a lot of video work that
I did you know some uh Saddler story
uh one in particular talking about the
book That Got Away uh you know whether I
should have stolen a copy of hegel's
phenomenology a second edition I did an
unboxing video because my mother-in-law
sent me a belated birthday present that
had a lot of cat related matters in it
um we uh did you know an Aristotle bonus
class sampler video I did a quick takes
video that's drawn quite a bit of
attention on the the question whether
questions or answers are more important
in philosophy but also more broadly in
life uh I did a book review video
towards the end of the month on one that
uh David fedeler sent me a while back
breakfast with senica excellent book you
can see my review below and I did a
story time with Sadler uh two HP
Lovecraft stories that uh were situated
in the same narrative Universe what we
call is dunan fantasy
Stories the cats of ulthar and the other
gods I also uh did some some podcast
work uh released a lot of podcast
episodes finished up the series on
Aristotle's categories which you know
there's a lot of those e episodes there
I'm getting ready to design a course on
Aristotle's categories by the way if
you're interested in that um I I did
some videos for my other academic
classes Rosemary or rather podcast
episodes Rosemary tongs Carol Gilligan's
ethics of care and Robert Audi's the
ethical significance of cost benefit
analysis and then I jumped into
finishing up a series that I started a
while ago and never quite got done on St
anel's monian so all of those are out
and you can find all of those podcast
episodes leading you through the
entirety of his first and very important
early work
so that's what we got done in
November what is coming up in the month
of December so I've got a lot of events
these are all in central time so if
you're in a different time zone make
sure to check your um you know time
difference so you're you're not showing
up an hour early an hour late if you
want to get in on them the first one is
going to be happening tomorrow and it is
my monthly AMA that has asked me
anything session it'll be happening at
noon Central time I'll answer questions
for about 90 minutes or so they can be
about philosophy they can be about life
they can be about music literature
politics whatever it is that you want to
bring to the table you just got to be
courteous with you know your fellow
guests and not get super impatient
because lots of people will be asking
questions I try to get to all of them
but it doesn't always happen and then
the very same day we got a real big
treat something that's kind of a uh you
know it's not a monthly thing that I do
it's actually quite an honor the
American philosophical practitioners
Association is having me on for an agura
and this is going to be sort of a
general interview about what I do with
my client-based practice of
philosophical counseling and Consulting
and Lou marinov will be interviewing me
asking me all sorts of things and then I
think it's open to the participants to
get to ask some questions as well so if
you want to get to know more about that
side of my work that could be something
that you would want to engage in I'll
put a link to that below as well as all
the other things too on the 9th at uh
noon we're going to be having what was
originally scheduled for last month but
I wasn't able to get to it understanding
anger we're going to be looking at eises
the ancient Greek playright the orista
these Trilogy of plays having to do with
with the house of Atrius and you know um
the eventual development
of legal justice in Athens supported by
Apollo and Athena against the furies so
there's a lot of really great stuff
about anger woven in there and we're
going to look at what lessons we can
draw from it also on the ninth for my
patreon supporters I will be having
philosophy chat this is a video
conferencing session where they can ask
me about whatever it is that they'd like
to and I'll you know uh be there to help
them out understanding philosophy
related matters sometimes there's a lot
of people sometimes there's just a few
but it's always a great conversation so
if you want to get in on that um you
know consider becoming a patreon
supporter it's one of the perks that we
offer at the $10 level on the 10th we're
going to try to do something that again
we were supposed to do last month and
hopefully it's going to happen this
month and that is at 300 p.m. on Sunday
the 10th I'm going to be premiering a
video about self-directed study of
Emmanuel Kant um so I've been putting
together some some stuff on that I'm
going to be filming it pretty soon and
we'll do a video premiere with live chat
for that on the 16th Scott truli will be
joining me again for classic metal class
and we are going to be focusing this
time on a topic which is really going to
highlight Scott I mean he's a professor
of guitar we're going to be talking
about great guitar solos and what makes
them great what what is there anything
that we can say is objective about it is
it purely subjective what goes into
great examples of soloing as an artist
so that's that's one I'm really looking
forward to Scott's going to have his
favorites I'm going to talk about some
of mine we'll solicit some suggestions
from the audience and we'll you know
we'll break them down maybe Scott will
even get out his his guitars he's got
about 30 of them I think sometimes you
see that in the background and and play
a few of them himself then on the 23rd
at noon we will be having worlds of
speculative fiction and this time this
is much anticipated by a lot of people
we are looking at the first two books of
Stephen Erikson's malison House of the
Fallen series which you know fan
recommended I'm really enjoying these
books just as I did with the Terry
pratchet so you know we'll do a video
premiere with live chat followed by a
zoom session and uh we'll we'll discuss
all of this in a good bit of detail that
it requires so those are the events
coming up this
month a lot of video work that I'm going
to be doing more interviews uh are lined
up I've got more books to review and
I'll probably do some more Sadler
stories I've got some things that I want
to talk about especially as the holiday
season approaches maybe do some personal
videos and I'll be doing some more quick
takes as well because there's some
things that I think could be helpful for
people um I'm also going to be doing
something that I've done in the past but
haven't done for a while I do
commissioned videos people are always
like will you do a video on this will
you do a video on this and my answer is
always do you want to pay for my time
and energy to you know stop doing what
I'm doing over here and do the thing
that you want me to to do and most of
the time people just say uh no but every
once in a while there's somebody who's
like yeah I'll do that I really want to
see this video so I've done commission
videos on n on haiger and now I'm going
to be doing one on Delo and guari uh
specifically on the notion of the body
without organs in in the first part of
anti atopus I'll also be doing a lot of
uh core concept videos on cons proma we
finished up with the second part we're
ready to move into the third part which
is really the center piece of it right
uh whether metaph pure metaphysics is is
indeed possible so we're going to be
doing some of those um we might do some
other core concept videos depending on
how quickly we proceed through the K and
then they'll watch out for some
announcement videos I'm going to be
doing some uh of those talking about
classes I already did one just recently
about my World Views and values online
class as we move into the new year there
should be videos coming out on Plato
four dialogues that we'll be looking at
the apology cedo uh youth afro and fedo
but there's also going to be
announcement videos for some of the
other classes that I'm going to be
offering and so that's a great segue
into talking about these online classes
so I am getting ready to teach two
academic classes in the spring for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
world uh religions of the world and uh
existentialist philosophy and literature
so I'll be I'll be shooting some more
core concept videos on key
existentialist thinkers but those of you
who'd like to study with me and you know
aren't going to be here in Milwaukee at
Milwaukee and of Art and Design I have a
Online Academy study with Sadler it's
called you can see the link to it below
and I am going to be offering two
synchronous classes this means that we
have regular meeting times I'll be doing
a synchronous class on the cardinal
virtues in stoicism that's wisdom
Justice Temperance and courage we're
going to be doing deep dives into these
looking at the different uh discussions
of them in stoic texts and in people
like Cicero who are attracted to
stoicism so that is going to be a online
class that if you want to you can enroll
in and you're going to learn an awful
lot I'm also going to be doing
concurrently with that but on a
different day philosophy of friendship
we're going to look at Aristotle Nick
McKay and ethics books 8 and N we're
going to look at Cicero's work on
friendship we're going to look at some
of senica's discussions we're going to
look at um uh Plutarch and his
discussions so it's friendship in the
ancient world and we're you know we
might bring in some others as well I'm
debating about doing Plato lius we we'll
see about that we can't pack in too much
but if that's something that you'd like
to study keep an eye out because I will
be doing an announcement video about it
we'll be pushing it out in social media
and you can enroll in that I'll also
have uh asynchronous classes that's
classes you can do at your own pace
coming out and I will announce those as
they become available as well so lot of
cool stuff coming up um podcast work you
know I've uh just started releasing to
my patreon
supporters um podcast episodes on URS K
Len the tombs of atan her second great
Earth scene novel um so that will be
continuing through the the early part of
the month and then I'm thinking actually
I'll probably do more Len right there is
uh some one-offs like her essay from
elfland to pipy there's the two early
Earth Sea Stories the rule of names and
um I'm forgetting the other one but uh
then there's a third Earth sea novel
which is really really good and I think
that people might be quite interested in
it
so I will probably do podcast episodes
continuing through the rest of December
on other Ursa
Len um novels so we'll probably do the
farthest Shore and we'll see if we can
get into tanu which is the fourth Earth
sea novel you know I don't want to
promise too much but so that is what
we've got going on this month obviously
we have the Christmas holiday coming up
and New Year's um my uh my kids are
going to be hanging out here for a good
bit of that that should be fun we're
going to do family things you know also
we're going to spend time at the cat
shelter and you know doing those sorts
of things but a lot of cool things
coming up in the month for those of you
who like the work that I do hope you can
join me for these online events and I
will see you out there in the internet
ether and uh we'll do some philosophy
together I hope you you have a great
month and uh yeah tune in to these
things the ones that you're particularly
interested
in